what do you do with this thing what look
at the question step back from it for a
moment because like I said the vast
Madrid you didn't even go within arm's
reach of a graph how could I come up
with a graph that would help me with a
question like this
what graph would it be
tell you and you're worth what graph is
gonna help me evaluate this integral
what integrals with that again
what what were they designed to solve
the problem is area right so I want to
get a picture for the area of this thing
with the x-axis between here and here
well I need a picture right so let's
just quickly put this together I'm only
drawing this right-hand side because I
know I'm gonna go between 1 & 2
okay what's this look like well like
usual I'll think about it without the
absolute values and then i'll add the
absolute value in kind of like a filter
right so X minus 3 it's gonna look down
here if 3 were down here I don't I am
drawing the rest of the axis because I
know I'm not gonna need it to take the
absolute value of that this part is not
going to change so there's that part of
graph and what happens to the rest of it
it flips up right it reflects so I've
got this kind of shape okay
what's this some intercept T this is
kind of important to me what's what's
its value it's gonna be 3 right cuz wife
was X minus 3 being shifted down that
way
across that way there's the value where
are my boundaries boundaries well that's
3 1 & 2 look like they'd be there in
there ok so this is the shape that I'm
after when you look at that you like oh
I don't even need calculus
what is that shape that's our trapezium
right at least it was the last I checked
so it's a trapezium
it has a now this is a bit tricky right
but you have learned trapezoidal rule so
at least you should have that it's not
like you only looked at this like four
years ago it has a height a height of
one unit from one to two what are the
lengths of the what are the sides that
I'm interested in which ones are they
because I'm not interested in all the
sides
I'm going to be interested in these two
right these are the parallel sides
as Erin said that one is one unit high
and this one is two unit own there you
go
so therefore this integral is this area
so it's the area of that trapezium at
the same shape so I'm pretty sure the
formula for the area of the trapezium is
H on to a plus B where a and B are your
parallel sides okay so what am I going
to get put in my values H in this case
is one a plus B there's my three
and then I go home and don't cry okay
raff graph graph graph graph graph even
if this wasn't going to be a trapezium
as you're going to see for this next
question the graph will be instructive
to help you form your area anyway